the newborn stage is over and now
we have our new challenges
[Music]
so
i gotta hurry i gotta hurry i got the
baby monitor in my pocket and the baby
has just gone down for a nap got the
boys
working on some school work and
listening out for him
and i've got to quickly get these
animals
hey before the baby gets up
babies on the homestead lots of work
but we can do it
silly cows are napping
in the morning and the goats are
waiting for fresh hay and titus is
waiting for fresh scratches
oh yeah what's your big billy
just gotta get in and get out right
right big guys you've been driving in
the mud
have you playing any muddy noise
so we have been opening this gate
and letting the cows and the goats come
out and forage
all this pasture here
they call this the cow pasture and that
the goat pasture
because ideally that's what it'll turn
into
we've got the temporary electric net
fence going all the way around
the tree line and last night
way back in the corner one of the
sections came down
so i could not let them out today and
they had to stay in the ducks
are molting again we still are not
getting any eggs from them
don't know why they are a little bit
older i think i probably need to hatch
out some eggs this year
our chickens have knocked over their
water again
they are not laying either so we have
not had
eggs and i'm getting pretty sad about it
with the gorgeous warm weather we've had
because even though it's rained every
night it has been sunny and warm during
the day the last couple of days
the bees are so happy they're doing very
well most days i try to wait till that
first morning nap
of the babies to come out and do the hay
that's pretty much all i gotta do in the
morning
so while he's laying down i try to run
out and do the hay
some mornings he comes with me because
he's
not taking a nap or what have you and
then
a lot of these nice days we all come out
and play
the boys come out with me and i lay
add a blanket for the baby to play on it
doesn't stay on the blanket anymore
he crawls all over the yard eating
leaves and twigs
just like a goat and he enjoys it
thoroughly
but because we had so much rain the
ground is really wet so that wasn't
really an option today even though
it's warm t-shirt weather he would get
soaking
through if he crawled on the ground
today unfortunately
but let's go see how the quail are
our quail house has turned out to work
perfectly
the quail are nice and protected in here
from the elements
and they still get some good sunlight in
here
coming through the sides so they're also
doing really well
but unfortunately they're not laying
eggs either
they're taking a little winter break
right now we actually had to buy
store-bought eggs because i haven't
been able to meet anybody locally yet
that sells eggs that would have been my
first choice
but i don't get out much and i don't
meet new people very often
so hopefully soon we'll have eggs again
this is about the time of year that our
chickens start laying again
after their winter break so we're
crossing our fingers we will have lots
of eggs soon and we will even start
incubating
once we have our fill of eggs and we're
back into being happy full bellies
we're gonna throw a good batch into the
incubator
and hatch out some quail some ducks and
some chickens
so i'm really looking forward to
hatching season
the garden is pretty much the same as it
was the last time
the one bed of garlic is all we have in
the ground
i sure do miss having a winter garden
where i can harvest greens and roots
all winter long but by next year we will
definitely have that
going again and i cannot wait i can't
wait to see this whole area
bright with green new growth in the
spring we are
super excited to start sewing seeds
we're not planting outside yet
but we are going to begin planting our
seeds
in here i've gone through most of my
seeds by now
and sorted and arranged them by category
i will be doing that one more time
before i'm officially into the sowing
season
but boy is it hard when you have
so many seeds one of those things that
we worked on this weekend
besides sorting the seeds was getting
the seed shelf
ready so we have heating mats grow
lights
on two shelves and then once
they have germinated and they're doing
okay
temperature wise and they don't need the
heat mats anymore we can then transfer
them up
to the top shelf because we have solar
coming from the roof then as they get
bigger and bigger
hopefully we'll be moving them out to a
sheltered location
as we transition them off one really
cool thing that i
am able to do this year is i became an
affiliate
with mary's heirloom seed i have been
promoting mary's seed for over a year
now
because of the quality and the service
that she provides
is above and beyond um pretty much
any other seed company out there and
luckily
she invited me to join her affiliate
program and so now
i have my own link that you guys can use
to shop for your mary's heirloom seed it
doesn't change the price of the seeds
for you
but it does help me out just a little
bit so if you want to use that i'll be
leaving it in the description down below
yeah baby black gold
this is some wonderful compost
that we were able to get because we
participate in the composting program
that ryan works for
so we turn in our compost and we get a
certain percent back those finished
compost
love it so excited to add this to our
new beds
something else i've been spending a lot
of time with
through the winter is i don't know if
you can see
but i've got all these beautiful plants
in the house all of my house plants i've
kind of gone overboard
i've been propagating a lot of them and
i'm hoping
that i can start sharing them with other
people we'll be sharing a lot of
vegetable seeds with some families we
were doing the
food box program through the summer
where we were handing out hundreds and
hundreds of food boxes to people
and we're looking to adopt some families
to
help get them started growing their own
veggies
and we're going to provide the seeds and
the information
and the guidance and mentorship as long
as they are willing
to provide the labor so if you know
anybody who lives in the carrollton
georgia area
have them reach out to me by email
wholesomerootsblog
gmail.com the goats are
fat and sassy we've got this
bar across here to keep the cow from
going in and
messing it up the cow uses the other
side as a lean-to shelter
we do have plans to make a pallet house
over on the cow pasture for the house
but for right now
the lean 2 is working just fine we've
had a really nice mild weather
for the most part a little bit too much
rain but i can't complain about that
because
i'd rather have that than a drought we
moved here
in the fall when we would normally be
breeding all of
our goats and after the move
nobody really came into heat thyme is
the only one that i have confirmed
bread from the fall there is one other
dough that might be bread
but i'm not even positive of that so
this week for some reason all of my
doughs have been coming into heat so we
have now bred
um kitty hearts fancy
and shady the ones that have been with
us for a long time
so that's pretty awesome we are not
breeding our most senior doe ruby she is
being retired
she probably could go another round but
her body condition
isn't good enough to be re-read anyway
so we're going to
continue to fatten her up and
hope that she can live a nice long
retirement with us for those of you that
have been with us for a long
time you've probably noticed our
reduced herd getting ready for a move
meant we had to reduce a lot we are
actually down to only 10 goats now can
you believe it
i i honestly cannot believe it i don't
remember the last time i only had 10
goats
but with adding in two cows and
moving to a new property i felt like
this is
a great place for us to be i feel like
i'm
really comfortable where we are we're
going to have some new kids coming along
i might choose a couple of does out of
those that i like to
and can see potential for and we may
keep them
but we also want to kind of
focus on what we're doing and the garden
and the cows
are going to be some pretty hefty
projects for us
um the garden being new we're going to
have to see what kind of battles that we
have to face
having a garden on this property in a
new property you never know
what kind of pests you're going to have
what kind of weeds are going to be
around
we don't know what the deer presence is
going to be we just really don't know
so we're hoping to get a good handle on
the garden in this location this year
and start lots of new projects
some new birds that we're going to be
hatching and
that's pretty much going to keep us busy
i think with a new baby
i mean he's eight months old now guys
but
that's actually when it starts to get a
little harder because he can crawl he
can get around
he can get into things so the newborn
stage is over
and now we have our new challenges
so it's going to be an interesting ride
make sure you check out our facebook
group and our facebook page
we have lots of information we share
there you can contact us there
to answer any of your questions and we'd
be happy to help you
also if you haven't checked out our wish
list in a while go ahead and check that
out i was just reminded that i even had
a wish list when we had a wonderful
subscriber purchase
a couple of things from there just this
week it filled
my heart with joy all right guys
i'm gonna go back in and hopefully be
able to finish a cup of coffee
before the baby gets up rowan
everything okay yep okay
thank you